okay so mayor of east town has been a
really gripping murder mystery that's
had some big twists and turns in it
episode 7 of season 1 has just dropped
and in this video we're going to be
recapping the plot
explaining its ending and giving our
thoughts on the show as a whole
if you enjoy the video then please smash
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this each
and every day
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoilers show i'm your host paul
aka the guy who doesn't cry over spilt
milk that's been thrown through his
living room window
now let's get into mayor of east town
okay so mayor of east town has centered
around the mystery of who killed aaron
mcmenamin
all the men are in suspicion and it's
led to several of them being under the
glare of our mayor
played by kate winslet years ago miss
lady hawk was a bit of a hero in the
town
but since then her reputation has
started to fall and she's now
not regarded as hailey several years ago
mei's son took his own life
and since then she's lived with her
mother helen played by jean smart
throughout the season mel losing her
child has been reflected in several of
the other characters
namely dawn bailey whose daughter katie
had been kidnapped
at one point she admitted that she had
lost her daughter the drug several years
before she was taken
and this series in some ways is very
much about mare trying to right the
wrongs of the past
so others have spared her pain mere's
daughter also lives with her
as well as her grandson who was
entrusted to her due to his mother's
drug addiction
however she was back on the road to
recovery wanting to gain full custody
and after mare planted drugs in a car
and got caught
she was let go from the case mayor took
things into her own hands
leading to a big revelation after
teaming up with colin zabal played by
evan peters
the pair managed to track down a man
that had been abducting women in the
area
colin caught some quicksilver and it led
to him being one of the most tragic
characters in the entire show
colin was a prodigy detective who we
discovered didn't actually solve the
case he was famous for
and though he and mayor went on a date
it was purely so she could stay close to
the case
mail like colin was very much someone
who had fame overshadowing their current
work and it led to her wrestling with
the pressure of living up to her past
colin still ended up a boner in the end
and the show has used several elements
like this to paint out its dour and
depressing tone
the entirety of east town is just a
miserable location
and people are willing to ruin their
relationships to get away from it
it's one of the grimiest settings i've
ever seen in a tv show
and the place could genuinely be
improved by pennywise
however what it does provide is a
gripping show and though colin and man
managed to discover
the man who had abducted katie it was
revealed that he had an alibi for the
night that eren was murdered
mayor was put back on the case and the
prime suspects lined up with deacon mark
admitting to being with her the night
she was killed
he also tried to hide her bike from the
police but in the end
he was vindicated aaron's ex was also
put under the microscope
as his girlfriend brianna came forward
and told the police
that he was missing on the morning that
she died however it was a man named john
ross who looked to be behind the crime
now being made a mystery there are
several twists and turns
and john's brother billy was even
implicated in the crime
episode six culminated with mayor going
after the latter
as they took a fishing trip together but
there was something that showed things
weren't as they seemed
and characters dylan and jess went to
chief carter who was overseeing the case
they presented a photograph of aaron in
bed with john and we discovered that he
was actually the father of her child
episode 7 opened with may stumbling
across jon pointing a gun at his brother
and after apprehending him he confessed
to it all
jon stated that he was aaron's secret
lover met her that night
and they fought over a gun which went
off and killed hit in the process
it all seemed to be tied up in a nice
little bow but as we know from mayor of
east town
nothing is as clean cut as it seems
looking back at the series as a whole
there are reoccurring themes in the show
that are repeated in several of the
characters
we very much get the feeling of guilt in
most of the parents
who feel they weren't really there for
their children mayor believes her son
ended his own life because she focused
on her work instead of him
dawn lost katie to drugs and was
desperate to get her back when she went
missing
and john's confession feels along the
same lines
the entire series is pretty much about
family and what people are willing to do
for the ones that they love whether it's
money or living a lie
they will sacrifice what they can in
order to make it so that their kids are
protected
how they blame themselves for the fate
of their children is of course reflected
in dawn blaming herself for katie going
missing
john and laurie for what we'll talk
about later and mayor first son taking
his own life
there's even dylan who though not
related to aaron's child dj
still feels like he has to be there for
him and there's this constant repetition
throughout every character they very
much live lies and hold on to hope
and as mere states they must learn to
live with the unacceptable
we'll talk about this later on in the
video but it's a very important idea to
deal with
john is sent to jail and at the
courthouse he asks his wife laurie if
she will raise dj
laurie has very much been a tragic
character in the series and she has lied
at several points to mare in order to
cover for her family
by the end of the episode her entire
life is ripped apart and between her and
mare there's definitely a feeling of
betrayal
she agrees to care for the child and
life starts to get
back to normal in east town also it
seems
deacon mark is freed and after mae says
she hopes the next place he goes to
treats him better
he states he has nowhere to go and that
east town is his home
mayor replies yep to this i think it
sums up how everyone is trapped within
the city
and though they know it's possible to
have a life outside of it they don't
want to risk
losing what they have they also hope
that life will improve there
and there's daughter states that her
mother secretly loves it there
because she believes she can make life
better in the town now we do see some of
these glimmers of hope when katie is
given a new home
and dj gets the ear surgery he needs
though we can see
lori is fighting through it now i don't
know if it's because the show has been a
constant kick in the balls
or because there was some dust in the
room but there may have
i said may have been a tear rolling down
my cheek during this
however it's not all sunshine and
rainbows and carrie relapses and ends up
going back to rehab
leaving her son in mae's care it's a
bittersweet win for the latter
and she ends up parting ways with
richard played by guy pierce
he's moving to a town over and though
they say they'll keep in touch
we know deep down that they'll both
drift apart it seems like things are as
happy as they'll get
but something keeps itching away about
the case to mare
not only does she doubt the ballistics
her ex-husband also says that jon
dropped him off on the night of the
murder
and we learned that he wasn't having an
affair at the time that we were told he
was
after visiting mr carroll things start
to become clear
after he states he's been noticing
things have been moving about his
property
this includes an eagle championship mug
the world's best pizza slicer
and a gun that matches the make and
model of the one that was used on eren
we discover this was kept in a shed
that's been a big focal point in the
series
and discover that there are two rounds
missing only he and another character
had access to it
and after mayor checks the cctv we see
that this is laurie and john's son ryan
she goes to his school and instantly he
realizes that the jig is up
and sprints home to his mother who we
learn knew about his involvement
like most of the characters she was
willing to do anything to protect him
mayor takes as many available officers
as she can to lorries
but he comes along quietly and confesses
too
it turns out that ryan didn't want his
family to fall further apart because of
his father's affair
which he discovered after finding text
messages on his phone
that night he ended up taking mr
carroll's gun from the shed
and he tried to scare her with it he
said that he only wanted to frighten
erin
but when she tried to grab the gun it
went off twice killing her in the
process
ryan called his dad who along with billy
helped him to move the body they hoped
that others would be blamed for the
crime
and laurie is furious that mayor has
destroyed her family
because she couldn't leave things alone
jon is in prison
and ryan will likely spend a lot of time
in juvenile detention
all of their lives are ruined and mayor
has to wrestle with whether she should
have solved the case
or kept the family together mayor
realizes that she's been putting cases
in the way to stop herself from grieving
for her son's death
and after saying goodbye to siobhan
who's left for school we see that life
returns to somewhat normality in the
town
we learned that ryan has started taking
writing classes and that the family have
now fully accepted dj
pastor mark returns to work and talks
about how we can always come back from
tragedies in the community
and this is very much shown here their
spirits are rising once more
and mayor goes to visit laurie unlike
colin's mother who slapped her after
destroying her life
laurie collapses into her arms in tears
and the ladder holds her
whilst having an epiphany mary realizes
that much like
laurie she's been holding on to this
pain for so long and that she hasn't
been able to let it out
finally doing this allowed laurie to
breathe once more and we end with mare
climbing back up into the attic
which we know is where she found her
son's body throughout the entire series
mare has been putting relationships
cases and whatever she can in the way of
accepting the grief
but seeing laurie break down and being
someone that has learned to live with it
is an empowering moment according to
executive producer craig zobel
the team were discussing whether the
camera should follow marionot
but they decided not to we very much
leave meg going off on her own to grieve
in privacy
leaving us watching her move on to the
next stage of her life
the entire show has been about watching
her trapped in this toxic cycle
but her moving on from it shows she's
now able to live with the unacceptable
it's a really impactful ending that
shows her not only growing
but also moving on to a higher level in
which he is no longer running from the
past
and instead moving towards it
now as for my thoughts on the series as
a whole i think there was a lot of highs
but a lot of lows too though they were
likely intentional
i've not experienced a show like this in
a long time where everyone seems to be
trapped in their own personal hell
and unable to escape from it colin's
death was a massive moment in the show
and i think it's probably the first
thing that people will think of when
they remember this series and years to
come
it was really shocking i love how the
show at several points felt pedestrian
so when this happened it completely
knocked the wind out of you
although it's slow paced the central
mystery is gripping and the acting in
this show is superb
this genuinely feels like prestige
television and though i feel like a [ __ ]
for saying that
i think it's the best way to describe
how well the series is made
tony this is so depressing i think it
works so well to paint out how bleak
life can be
it's a really outstanding series that
has a lot of twists and turns
and though i doubt i'll be revisiting it
that doesn't mean i didn't enjoy it
kate winslet will no doubt get a lot of
attention for her performance
and she'll probably gone as some awards
from it too these are much deserved
america's town gets an a out of ten now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the finale
and the series as a whole as a thank you
for interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize through on the 30th
of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on mere beast
town the winners of last month's
competition are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
lucifer season 5 part 2
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace